[Music]
what's up everybody it's lil yachty and
you're watching the premiere of snack on
first week feast
these are my favorite snacks
[Music]
all right guys so i just want to give a
disclaimer first before we start this
all right because i understand
the program predicament over here and i
just want you guys know that these
snacks
i love these are my favorite snacks i
want you guys to look at me crazy
because i know you guys are going to
think
wow that guy there probably has
high blood pressure and a few other
things and he's probably not going to
live that long but
these are just the things that i'm into
all right so first my favorite candy of
all time is m
m's peanut m ms i love my favorite
but eminem minis for some reason
they taste better mmm small one
they're tiny and they're a little bit
harder
mmm it tastes better frozen
they don't lose i literally just had a
bag of these while i came in here
and i keep a bag on me at all time i got
a bag of my car
in my refrigerator all times keep them
on me i think i need an eminem deal
i need a deal
i'll cross the balls i'm trustees so i
love
love love peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches i love uncrustables i mean
like i hate crafts
only thing about incredibles that i
[ __ ] hate is so much [ __ ] jelly
i'm a peanut butter guy so they should
give you the option like hey less jelly
there's so much [ __ ] jelly so when i
eat my crystals i eat them
around and i i can never eat the middle
ear because that middle layer is
too much jelly
i love my sandwiches on white bread so
it's a plus i think now they sell them
on whole wheat i think you can not even
get them on whole wheat
i don't know who's buying that [ __ ] this
one like it looks like it has a little
bit more peanut butter
i use the perfect stuff the bread is
always soft
oh y'all putting on drinks
[Music]
one of my homies put me on donut sticks
brought to school and i was like
damn it just make you feel real fat
it'll make you feel real fat real fast
go for coffee i don't drink coffee now
i'm gonna stick here
[Music]
do it's my favorite snack
how the [ __ ] did y'all even get these
it's not girl scout season i'm taking it
i don't have these i'm taking these
anyways
shouts out to jada that's my personal
girl scout who hits me up when is that
time she take my order she give me right
every time i'm going straight to my door
stop jada shout out to you
anyways this cookie
is so good it's the best girl scout
without debating anybody
has a problem they can fight me
obviously but it's so good so what they
did was like a season ago two seasons
ago
two or three i think two they did a
patch and i don't know what was going on
they did a bachelor they did
silverbacks now everybody knows girl
scout cookies they come clear bag
they did a batch when it was silver bags
and i wasn't feeling that
it was it wasn't good it was they
changed this recipe on it
it was disgusting and my heart was
broken they went right back to clear
back the next season
i said they must have got multiple
complaints they must have got my letters
in the mail
looking at this box just makes me happy
you put these in refrigerator then get
cold
moment of silence damn
carville ice cream cake i used to always
call it carnival to my ex
my ex told me it's carvel just never
actually read it i don't know
god i'm eating my stomach is like what
are you doing right now you're just
feeding me
assorted [ __ ] you're tripping that's
just good as [ __ ]
i feel like this is illegal i feel like
i'm like coming to crime
like i shouldn't be eating this it
should be to celebrate someone's birth
sometimes you just need it sometimes you
really need it
you gotta have it i mean you gotta lie
and tell the person behind the counter
happy birthday too and then you just
make someone's name up
it has to say happy birthday to somebody
that's just good it's good
all right guys those were my favorite
snacks some of them at least i'm lil
yachty
and make sure you check out my new song
love music
out on all platforms now i hope you guys
enjoyed this
and don't make too much fun
you